j'étais quand même sous son emprise en
quelque sorte mais c'était une emprise
extrêmement
inspirante à 15 ans vous allez faire vos
vos débuts auprès de du réalisateur
Benoît Jaco c'était les mendiant et vous
allez partir avec lui vivre avec lui
comment on réagit vos parents
en fait je pense que je je enfin c'est
difficile de parler de soi et surtout de
de se projeter dans le le regard que que
vos parents peuvent avoir sur vous mais
ce que j'ai pu ce que j'ai établi ou
essayer de comprendre par la suite
justement puisque moi j'ai des enfants
c'est que je pense qu'en
fait j'avais quelque chose de tellement
déterminé et d'assez rassurant que je me
présentait ou comme une une jeune fille
très structurée voilà et que du coup en
fait c'est comm comme si c'était
compliqué d'imaginer que je puisse
courir le moindre
danger je ne suis pas quelqu'un je pense
d'ailleurs toujours aujourd'hui qui
inspire forcément aux autres un
sentiment ou un désir de protection
comme s'il pouvait rien m'arriver voilà
j'aime bien faire croire que il y a pas
besoin de j'ai pas besoin d' elle a bien
dit faire
croire qu'est-ce que vous recherchiez
auprès de d'un homme beaucoup plus âgé
que vous d'abord il m'a il je je sais
pas ce que je enfin d'abord c'était
quelqu'un d'extrêmement séduisant moi
qui vivais beaucoup dans l'imaginaire
qui qui était très très euh je je je
passais mon temps à lire j'étais
vraiment une une voilà je j'étais très
aussi dans le Romanis dans le romantique
voyez et lui avait tout représentait
tout ça voilà c'était quelqu'un de très
habité de très euh très intelligent qui
qui qui de de et qui rendait de brillant
et qui rendait la vie euh c'est
quelqu'un qui réinventait la vie
vraiment alors ensuite évidemment qu'il
avait énormément d'influence sur moi et
que j'étais quand même sous son emprise
en quelque sorte mais c'était une
emprise
extrêmement inspirante
[Musique]
extrêmement P malio un pig Malion
ouais c'est une fille qui a vécu très
jeune avec un homme et qui est resté
assez longtemps avec lui et
qui peut-être n'a pas eu
d'adolescence qui a été comme ça projeté
très vite dans un monde où l'amour était
devenu sa seule raison d'être et qui qui
qui décide de de découvrir la vie le
monde extérieur et surtout d'apprendre
à découvrir la liberté savoir ce que
c'est que la liberté qui aimerait savoir
ce que c'est que la liberté elle avait
vécu comme ça des moments très on est
dans un univers très clos fermé sur
eux-même avec cet homme elle a un point
de côté elle elle a plus de souffle elle
a besoin
de de s'arrêter pour pouvoir repartir et
donc ça commence par le point de côté et
ce qui suit c'est le nouveau départ
[Musique]
elle a l'âge
pas l'âge de raison mais l'âge auquel on
est censé être une une femme 21 ans
maintenant il est plus question de jouer
les enfants de jouer les petites filles
il faut être une femme physiquement
c'est une femme et en fait elle n'a
pas appris à être une femme c'est-à-dire
qu'elle a été une femme très jeune et
très assez violemment comme ça et donc
c'est vrai qu'avec les hommes elle a ce
rapport
ambigu à la fois elle cherche en en une
un soutien et
un une protection mais cette jeune fille
apprend aussi qu'il faut s'aimer
soi-même pour pouvoir aimer les autres
êtes-vous désenchanté jeudit
godr non non
non